in pub polar 3 - Oh everybody welcome to
another episode of genius brain I am
your host Sir George it's a powwow and I
am your co-host David so today we also
have another guest because this is him
just recording - the second Nick the
[ __ ] ear dumb Nick's like oh
he's like an official like he's been in
like a [ __ ] ton of episodes I don't know
my last name is done not dumb dumb oh no
you're saying I'm guy dumb it's n its
two ends M and B right I got it Mickey
dumb dumb it's dumb what's done is that
uh vinum Lee that's Irish why you saw my
Rich Dad you [ __ ] deceiver hey man
Asian are you well my dad immigrated
here from Taiwan they just heard his
name and they were like when it's gonna
be done so what's the original [ __ ] I
think it supposed to be like tin or
something like that it could be anything
apparently I was fooled because when I
when I originally called them up
betrayed me I thought it was gonna be
some [ __ ] white guy or something and
then I saw this little Asian guy with
big-ass ears he goes I'm Nick Dunne
looks like [ __ ] deceiver dude you
deceive me so bad another one you can
teach me [ __ ] what are you gonna [ __ ]
teach me but the bo staff you [ __ ]
Chuck's a little red thing on the spear
you spinning around I'm not here for
wushu classes sir thank you yeah turtle
nest
yo what we're gonna get oh actually I'm
have to look a little bit of this up but
did you guys hear the [ __ ] I guess you
know you know how a lot of athletics are
getting into being a little more
inclusive so in terms of body type
oh yeah yeah you know cuz when we were
growing up when we saw all the stuff
that we saw when it came to sports and
athletics or whatever that it was it was
only um big black guy big black guy
strong white guy buff buff buff skinny
buff skinny buff skinny but for example
like when you go into target now when I
went to target not too long ago maybe a
couple of weeks ago I saw
I guess the word would be plus size like
plus-sized mannequins right and I never
saw that [ __ ] growing up but you see
that everywhere now
and I'm not making a statement about it
I'm just saying like this is wavin hates
him he says they're gross
oh yeah that's exactly you know what I
hated that I would hate [ __ ] like this
when I you know I'm still a big guy now
but when I was bigger I would see
clothing on a mannequin and I'm like
that looks great and then I put it on
myself I was like this [ __ ] looks
terrible it wholly looks good on a
skinnier mannequin but nowadays people
are being uh pretty inclusive but there
was a lady who wrote this article about
so 19 kind of had a campaign where
they're being inclusive because they
want to make more money yeah marketing
tool dude it's a marketing tool it's a
business tool that she kind of I believe
she's a writer for The Huffington Post
and she kind of just went on this tirade
where she was saying how how stupid it
is how Nike is just basically promoting
obesity and she she got a lot of flack
for it and I guess like what people are
saying with that is that you know how is
that promoting OBC they're just trying
to add like diversity within their brand
I just see if Nike comes out with
athletic [ __ ] for fat people that just
means that they're promoting them to
lose weight yeah yeah well you don't
think fat people want to look good while
they [ __ ] walk around the block or
bike or whatever like they you know in
athleisure to is just it's just fashion
now yeah there's people that don't even
work out that wear like tights and
shorts and sneakers and whatever like
that's me dude I don't even work out in
my way that [ __ ] yeah it's it's weird
because I don't know because you know
what I find it very odd it's number one
what the [ __ ] is your deal yeah you know
I mean why is it important to you who
cares
you're promoting OBC well actually the
funny thing is fat people are probably
the ones who need the athletic clothes
the [ __ ] most yeah we need it the
most like we're the ones trying to lose
weight you [ __ ] maybe that's number one
reason that's stopping larger people
from working out is they don't have
athletic wear exactly
number one reason yeah there's there's a
psychology behind it too like when
you're at the gym and you're wearing
this raggedy-ass t-shirt and some
[ __ ] nasty ass like gym clothes like
how back in a day like that's what you
wore gym clothes like literally old
clothes right and then you see other
people now looking good mm-hmm and now
you don't want to go to the gym because
yeah you do right so true then big
people I feel like they would want
something so they look fresh and also
like when you take care of yourself
fashion wise you start wanting to take
care of your body too uh it goes
hand-in-hand cuz why don't you market
that to that demographic man make it for
everyone yeah and I don't know what's
wrong with this [ __ ] where the [ __ ] is
she saying like oh my god it promotes
this like nobody's me that's some weird
[ __ ] dude it's like yeah he's not
huffing the opposed it's telegraphists a
UK or British [ __ ] sensitive yeah I
was like so I mean let's just use some
of the words that she use she said that
uh so this is from poor people People
magazine but they're kind of
paraphrasing what she's saying she goes
so representation matters which is why
celebrities like Jameela Jamil and they
score Laurence are speaking out in
support of Nike after the sportswear
company unveiled curvy mannequins at
their London store and a British writer
from Telegraph wrote a body shaming
Colin calling them a metonym gergich
gargantuan up dude
gargantuan dam is not even gargantuan
this is what people look like yeah dude
people look like this she's in America
she sounds like she has a problem with
her own [ __ ] she probably has like what
do you call it that body morphing yeah
dysmorphia and man that's such a twisted
way to look at ya never have I ever
walked by a [ __ ] plus-size mannequin
and been like this is fat shaming this
is not okay it's like dude this is this
is what people look like I think what
this [ __ ] doing is fat shaming yeah
she's like oh fat people shouldn't even
have gym clothes or name is what what
the [ __ ] her name is uh Tanya gold so on
the people myth so while most celebrated
the new mannequins Tanya gold a
columnist for the UK
paper The Telegraph wrote on Sunday that
she fears the war on obesity is lost
because the company is promoting larger
sizes and kind of what Nike wrote is to
celebrate the diversity and inclusivity
of sport the space will not just
celebrate local elite and grassroot
athletes through visual content but also
show Nike Plus size and pair of pair of
sport mannequins for the first time on a
retail space and that's what Nike wrote
in their press release and her response
was you know the mannequins are
gargantuan she is in every someone shoes
this is her describing the mannequins
she is in every measure obese and she is
not reading herself for a run in her
shiny Nike gear
she cannot run she is more likely
pre-diabetic and on her way to a hip
replacement damn wow that's that's so
that's what's the logic they're like why
why does that why is she going all the
way if I could tap into this bitch's
mind do it joke you know I think what
she's afraid of is people feeling like
they did enough mmm so like let's say
she's a what she's afraid of is like
okay this person obviously you know it's
like it's like she's afraid of ego
fluffin like oh this person wears these
athletic clothes and they think they're
fit when they're not and it's like no
that dude it's not even up to you but I
can tap into these kind of weird people
only because of social media and how
much comments we have to deal with and
over the years I understand a lot of
different mind states yeah and this is
coming from a self righteous place right
and a lottery self right yeah yeah a lot
of people like they just get outraged
and angry about what other people are
doing because they go that's not how
you're supposed to do it I think it
comes from that piece that that that
kind of hit that's exactly yeah and then
like if it's like so there's only one
way to look at the world for these
people and it's it's only their way they
can't see it any other option and what
you know I think in her her perspective
it's basically if you let these fat
people be comfortable they'll never want
to change that's what this [ __ ] is
probably so she wants to fat shame
people mall I mean she's she's kind of
like alluding to the fact that she's
saying people in today's society are
normalized
obesity as as if it's okay and I think
that she completely missed the point of
this Nike campaign yeah I don't think
Nike is saying or any other sports
company or even any general clothing
like Target is saying that it's it's
completely healthy to be big that's not
their thing and number one on a business
aspect it's really not their thing
either they're being inclusive because
number one it sells because there are
big people in this world and now they
want to go to the gym yeah yeah and on
top of that two big people need [ __ ]
clothes too
yeah so you know it just it's not I
don't think it adversely promotes it's
not like secondhand smoke it's not
voting obesity and by the way just like
I said before big people need athletic
clothes as well yeah what does she
expect like big people to get bed sheets
and wrap that around themselves and go
to the gym like where that's not drive
fit like what if today they decide to
change their lives and they want to walk
around and then they're like well I
don't have any athletic clothes I mean I
feel weird like because all I have our
dresses or whatever right like like why
should they Nikes actually promoting it
because then they're creating a space
let's get you started
I'm sure secondly I'm sure Nike did
their homework and they found that
there's a market for that because I'm
pretty sure there's been a lot of bigger
people that have been wanting to work
out or whatever the case may be
yeah and they may not feel comfortable
like you said yeah they don't want to
have some clothes they could train it
hello everybody this podcast is brought
to you by purple my friends that's pu r
PL e now if I haven't mentioned this
before imma say it again I loves me
my purple mattress I woke up in pain
from my stiff stiff mattress because
nobody told me about purple nobody told
me about the amazing technology that
purple has that it can keep me cool that
it can be both firm and soft at the same
time and that's what a purple mattress
is and that's why I love it the purple
mattress will probably feel different
than anything you've ever experienced
because it uses this brand new material
that was developed by an actual rocket
scientist it was not like the memory
foam that I'm used to or even you're
used to my friends the purple material
feels very unique because it's both firm
and soft at the same time so it keeps
everything supported while still feeling
real
comfortable Platz is breathable so it
sleeps cool
very important for me I'm a sweaty
sweaty man I need to sleep
cool 100 night risk-free trial if you're
not fully satisfied you can return your
mattress for a full refund backed by a
10 year warranty free shipping and
returns free in-home setup an old
mattress removal Wow ha you're going to
love purple and right now my listeners
will get a free purple pillow with the
purchase of mattress that's in addition
to the great free gifts they're offering
site-wide just text brain to eight four
- eight eight eight the only way to get
this free pillow is to text brain to
eight four - eight eight eight
that's be are a I n to eight four eight
eight that's two as in tio to eight four
eight eight eight message and data rates
may apply this podcast was brought to
you by wireless earbuds from Ray Khan
now if you've never had any form of
wireless earbuds specifically these Ray
Conniff it these son I'm gonna tell you
this right now you're in for a treat
number one very easy to use great
battery life and on top of that they
look really dope super cool I love them
I use them all the time specifically
when I go on my walks and I'm working
out or even beyond that if I just want
to listen to music in bed because
sometimes when you listen to music in
bed and you wake up all the wires are
tangled you don't need to mess with any
of that with wireless earbuds rake on
earbud start at about half the price of
any other premium wireless earbuds on
the market and they sound amazing cuz
you know these things get pricey but I'm
telling you rake on is super affordable
I love them to death ray cons c50
wireless earbuds have totally changed
the game they're super comfortable and
they're you know they're pretty much
easy to take any where so rate con
offers their waterless earbuds for
everyone in a range of you know
different fun colors and I guarantee you
once again at an unbeatable price so go
to buy rake on Comm slash brain to get
20% off your order
that's by rake on Comm slash brain for
20% off rake on wireless earbuds if
you've been eyeing a pair now is the
time to get an amazing deal
one more time by rakin calm / brain and
the ones that I love the most people are
my rake on wireless e-50 earbuds
probably my favorite feature about these
aside from the fact that they don't have
wires it's just how easy they are to use
they're in this little case this little
charging case and you want to use them
you pop them out and they connect via
bluetooth it's amazing I love it she
kind of reminds me of the people who
make fun of fat people at gyms yeah and
who cares dude who care like if if Nike
wants a cell to a larger like a bigger
people audience who cares yeah like
let's do you see I never see I never I
never understood people making fun of
fat people working out like so so like
sometimes they'll be fat people running
around the block there'll be people at
the gym and then like I always heard of
this mysterious thing where people like
they're afraid of getting made fun of
and I'm like who makes fun of you like
who's that [ __ ] low yeah like I make
fun of fat people just being normal
people yeah food and just being like
normal walking around I mean that's
everyday people [ __ ] but when I see them
working out I'm like oh [ __ ] I don't see
this this fat joke anymore what I see is
somebody challenging themselves and I
got to give respect to that traitor I
understand too because when I when I was
younger too when I was bigger I think I
will you don't think I was kind of
self-conscious going to the gym I mean I
did it anyways I didn't you know my
mental way I'm just like I'm not gonna
be a little puss just go to the [ __ ]
gym and I think it's because I don't
know whether it's because societal
pressure or whatever but you sit there
and you compare yourself to other people
a lot of the times when you're bigger
number one when you're a very very large
person there's a lot of mental stuff
that kind of gets you there to that
point you know self-esteem issues
whatever happened your your weird
connection with food and just coping and
so to put yourself out there in public
in a body that most people say is
disgusting in a place like a gym even
though I call it the hospital for the
people who need it the most it doesn't
seem like that's the place where it is
right because even promotions for
24-hour fitness or whatever is these
people who are super athletic and so
sometimes when people are you know going
to their personal [ __ ] they look at this
Jen they don't think of that it's a
place for them yeah that's why a lot of
these fitness programs they say do it in
the comfort of your home and a lot of
larger people I believe specifically
even me preferred doing it at home well
not now but when I was younger I was
very much like that like I didn't want
to go to a gym because I didn't want to
be judged and sometimes too when we put
up these weights and it's not as much as
other people it makes you feel bad for
some [ __ ] reason you're always
comparing yourself to somebody else
we're always cracking jokes all the
trainers at the gym when Bart comes in
and lifts everyone's like dude I was I
was gonna squat today oh yeah loading up
like plates and relax yeah [ __ ] that but
it's also like gyms should take note
like this is what they should be
marketing to yeah yeah no more of like
yeah but you want to you want to relate
to the people that I mean you wanna you
want you want the people that are gonna
work out anyway
but how am i again that's what a like
planet I think Planet Fitness does yeah
I think cruncher the fitness gym that
does like $10 a month like their whole
thing is relating to people that are
tired of like the quote unquote
douchebag people in the gym well let's
go Fitness Planet Fitness yeah and like
they're their whole marketing brain is
like catering to people that wouldn't
normally have a gym membership
yeah and that's [ __ ] genius because
that's what you want and at the end of
the day like I feel like for me too when
I before I started doing more like
fitness and strength conditioning stuff
I would always have like in my head
while I was like fighting a lot I'd
always see all these dudes that are like
buff is [ __ ] and whatever and it would
make me feel self-conscious in a weird
way but I'd always be like man but they
can't fight though which is such like a
[ __ ] thinking yeah I mean it's very
like harmful but you no matter who you
are you always play those mental
gymnastics with yourself where you could
put someone else down or you feel
self-conscious about you know an
athletic clothing to like I'm not sure
how everybody else feels about it yeah
when athletic clothing when you wear
some ass it makes you feel like a [ __ ]
athlete you feel tight yo I'm telling
you like if you're if you're a big
person and you want some if you want to
feel good in the gym I feel like half of
that battle is just also wanting to look
good too yes and if there's like this
clothing that does that for you there's
a reason why people [ __ ] with barbell
there's a reason why I will [ __ ] with
Nike and Adidas for some [ __ ]
when you wear that Nike shirt that Nike
shorts it makes you want to workout
makes you about that your armor yeah
yeah it's like it's like it empowers you
to [ __ ] work out and [ __ ] cuz imagine
- for somebody who's 400 pounds right
they go into a Nike store and they
literally can't wear a single [ __ ]
clothing in that whole store yeah how
defeating would that be Yeah right and
if but if they had something on them and
they go cool like this actually makes me
want to go out and do something why the
[ __ ] not I think it's not only genius I
think it's just you know it's a really
good thing to do for so exactly what
they should be doing no man it's it's
crazy because I have such a different
Association I think one I'm very like
much in my own world because I never
sized myself up with other people in the
gym I've done that like when I'm doing
anything of skill and competition so
it's like I'm sizing myself up with
someone sparring or whatever yeah but I
never had this feeling of intimidation
it's always been a playground because
I'm there to play with my friends and
check out girls yeah yeah so like I'm
like oh let's go to the gym like there's
hot girls and then like maybe we could
talk to them and then it's like oh let's
go there and lift some stuff so like I
never really had this negative
association so it was difficult for me
to empathize and understand because I
remember I would invite people to
barbell and then they're like now I'm
intimidated and why everyone there's
nice yeah and then I would be like kind
of hurt because I'm like what you don't
wanna go with me and play like it's
almost like I'm inviting them to Chuck E
Cheese and they don't want to come with
yeah yeah yeah
and I'm like why like what are you
afraid of like people there are really
[ __ ] nice oh for sure when I when I
some some of my friends for Sacramento
they want to come out and they they want
to work out I'm like well we can go to
barbell right and you can come with me
and then you could meet Barden these are
like close friend yeah and I got nah man
it's gonna be too crazy I was like it's
a [ __ ] gym you work out how are the
[ __ ] you want yeah you know and I always
have to tell people who remind them that
barbell is probably one of the nicest
[ __ ] gyms I've ever been to in my
life
more so than 24-hour Fitness do 24 hours
have they have a lot of douche bags that
go there yeah I don't
yeah those years of the [ __ ] worse
like when guys are peacocking yeah like
I'm just like man like why are you
putting on a show like just get out of
here I want to work out like stop
hogging the machine let me tell you this
[ __ ] story man
I was I used to go to 24-hour out in
South Pasadena late at night um there's
just not a lot of people there so
there's one [ __ ] guy I'm you know I'm
not benching a lot I just had a 45 and a
25 on there and the guy as I'm benching
and I put it down the guy comes up and
he just takes my 25 pound happens all
the time
yeah that's so [ __ ] real I get up and
I just [ __ ] snatch it out of his hand
I'm like the [ __ ] are you doing man and
he goes like will you set it down I was
like does it look like I'm [ __ ] done
with this you know and obviously people
are looking around like he's a [ __ ]
dumbass and he's looking at me like I
did something wrong you know what I mean
in this type of environment too that I
think people get intimidated at gyms
because of people like that dude what a
[ __ ] that's a guy that's never been
punched in the [ __ ] headache it yeah
it is the rudest that is so rude like
there's no other plates there yeah by
the way why was this Jack guy he would
have never done that yeah there so it
was he huh what was he like so Nikki I'm
like the different world if I was his
jacked human being and I didn't look
like this goofy asian guy I guarantee
you he would have never done that that's
the same [ __ ] guy that was in the
Ikea parking lot yes
you know and it's just it's kind of odd
when I look at that situation and it
does make sense why people get
intimidated
these guys are in a [ __ ] ball yeah
[ __ ] beats by draping like he's
living in his own world also is not that
cool to work out that must be so hard to
work house yeah and in my mind to like
the only thing I'm thinking about is you
know you may be buffer than me but if I
throw a 45 pound pound plate at your
[ __ ] teeth your muscles will do [ __ ]
you know and I just you know it's just
enraging and I'm just sitting there just
like what are you doing obviously other
people at the gym were dogging him to
like what the [ __ ] are you doing guy
yeah so here's a bad rap [ __ ] so and
I as a grown up I told him you should do
it I told one of the staff members about
this Jack isn't they kicked them out
that night because you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] bro that is the rudest ever
yeah do you hear about that there was a
story that was like a long time ago but
it was a kid was deadlifting and some
dude oh you
strap you like shove them and you're
like oh dude you're a piece of [ __ ] you
screw this long video guide that was a
kid that was dead lifting some way and
then you [ __ ] hit him while he was
dead lifting yeah so while he was
strapped in yeah strap his foot on it
and he slanted that's what it was yeah
what a [ __ ] prick I forgot I think he
was saying he was too loud or he was
banging his yeah [ __ ] off bro guys never
deadlift in his lifetime you didn't even
work at the gym yeah he didn't even wear
he wasn't even a set her self-righteous
crazy guy because in his mind he's
[ __ ] like oh this is gym etiquette
yeah but it's like nah dude sometimes
when you're lifting heavy weight and
you're thrown some weight around
plates are gonna slam against the floor
I'm sorry because it's such an odd thing
to even in my case when that guy took
the weight off let's just say for
example he thought that I was done with
my set you should have asked me yeah you
could it came up to me hey man oh you'd
like everybody else does in the gym
yeah dude there's only two plates yeah
it's a 24-hour fitness they'll have more
plates elsewhere exactly you're not
guarantee you he's the kind of guy that
will sue you if you smack off their work
that was so unwarranted because he was
trying to be a [ __ ] [ __ ] dude yeah
I'm just like trying to Punk me or
something or whatever and mind you -
it's like passive-aggressive weirdness
it's such a [ __ ] move it's like either
[ __ ] kill me or don't do it at all
that's my philosophy
like he that's so [ __ ] this is how I
feel - I feel like he he took the plate
and he assumed that I wasn't gonna say
anything yeah you know that's the other
[ __ ] up and it makes me feel really
small he thought I can get away with
yeah so you know when I got up and I
snatched it out of his hand I bet she
was like oh [ __ ] what up what's my next
move it's like well your next move is
either you're gonna [ __ ] swing at me
or what's gonna guess what he's gonna
tell on you I guess what I did I [ __ ]
like you're an adult now David no I
don't what's the point you know I'm not
gonna do he was kind buff but the other
thing was it was causing a commotion
because other people were giving him
[ __ ] - I was like well [ __ ] I call the
staff member over and then I told him
I'll yell this guy [ __ ] just snatch
the weight out of my barbell yeah and
the guy got kicked out but it's just the
concept that somebody could do that to
you
for no [ __ ] what was the reason and I
think that's what begins me frustrated -
I can't figure out his logic like why
did you do it I think it's more like
user dope
you go trippin I don't know like this is
what I always wonder to do why people
bully each other this way because every
culture bullies each other in different
ways right
or do they feel like like you know like
I think I think when it comes to
bullying they attack or treat people
weird like they they bully those that
they think they could have won over yeah
and I feel like man bullying happens in
Asian culture but not like that yeah
it's very different right so it
blindsides me like what's going on here
now mind you I have been punked a
24-hour - it was the k-town one there's
that there's a k-town when there's some
[ __ ] precarious people in there
sometimes I don't know now but this is
why I lived in k-town back in the day
but the way that guy punked it was a
very thug like so I disrespected his
thuggish I was on a lat pulldown machine
I think I was like yo that's my machine
ass like damn straight it is yeah kind
of bullying I understand cuz it's like
some thug [ __ ]
you know man you know [ __ ] bolo yeung
yeah [ __ ] Chong Li from yeah he's a
boy at the gym
oh I respect it cuz he's a [ __ ] yeah
maniac like he'll come up and he doesn't
even say can I have you'll be working
out and he'll go huh
alright I know that that's my Cyrus I
honestly would respect that is more than
someone taking a [ __ ] plate and
walking on a passive-aggressive you mean
it's like [ __ ] [ __ ] if he came up and
then he was like get off it's my turn I
would have been like yes sir
but if he does if he just pulls the
weight off I'm like what am I supposed
to do am I supposed to fight like I
don't understand don't put me in this
situation
yeah like I don't understand this
communication like like I don't know man
it's here it's just very weird I feel
like if we if we just boiled it down as
if you're not about that life
don't [ __ ] act like oh right because
that dude wasn't about that type of life
the other guy that punked me said oh
that's my machine he's about that life
I'm gonna get up and move and obviously
even the people around us knew yo that's
his machine don't [ __ ] touch that
[ __ ] right it's like it's like Church
bullying was worse than when I get
bullied by white people it's weird and
then so I'm like okay well how did they
how do they deal with this and how do
they battle it out cuz I'm so far
removed
that culture I want to understand
because it's like a Jedi mind trick it's
not what's going on I feel I'm just
[ __ ] flabbergasted yeah [ __ ] like it
makes me you guys got to find a new gym
yeah why don't go to that 24 hour at all
so it's it's when you're also to you you
know just to put it in perspective I
mean I'm there at 1:00 a.m. to him
there's a lot of weirdos at that time
yeah so when you're with a bunch the
weirdo time you're gonna meet a lot of
weird people like I had this other
[ __ ] soaked leaf and I used to work
at 24-hour that 24-hour in the morning
and there was without [ __ ] failed
this roided-out Beachbody buff guy right
with this big fake titted girlfriend and
he would scream and fight every morning
that's duh I kid you not you could even
add up when I have Cleveland tell the
story because he could explain it better
but it was to the point where they would
do a workout and without fail cliff is
like watch they're gonna fight again and
they would do some [ __ ] like this I'm
not remembering a verbatim but it would
be something on some [ __ ] like I told
you to [ __ ] do it this way why are
you doing it that way I'm trying my best
what the [ __ ] yell at me then just
[ __ ] do it that way and then she
starts crying and he will come up he go
baby I'm so sorry
I'm sorry I'm like dude they definitely
have crazy sex or he beats her or some
[ __ ] that's how I try my client it was
crazy though but his staff never said
keep it down or anything I mean I this
was in the morning so it was pretty heck
is he you know but the guy would just
scream at her and then she cries and he
starts kissing or apologizing but it was
the same uncomfortable space that's
abuse that's some abuse that's a beer so
you know just to wrap it back I can
understand why people are intimidated at
gyms yeah especially commercial gyms
yeah that's true cuz barbell is like a
it's like a community like everyone kind
of knows each other yeah yeah and
there's a lot of respect because people
just go in and do their work
I used to even be so nervous when I was
like in my when I first started signed
up for 24 right like early 20,000 18 I
how did you sign up I signed I just went
to the place and I signed up mmm and so
when I this is before you could do it
online is [ __ ] so I signed up at the
place and I went there and I just
remember I even got nervous to ask
somebody how many sets they have left
like I couldn't even I would just sit
there and wait because I was such a
nervous little [ __ ] yeah cuz I just
felt uncomfortable in the gym and I
didn't want to ask them hey man how many
sets do you have left
no why I can't even put into words the
reasoning behind that nervousness I just
know that in that space I felt very
uncomfortable and it almost felt
unwarranted for me to ask somebody to
use the bench yeah so I would sit there
and I would wait instead of yes you know
and later on - after I got stronger
physically stronger than for some reason
I felt like more of a right yeah I had
more of a right now just know how many
sets do you have left and then it's like
you could watch me put the [ __ ] up you
know this is this is why you hate
lifting weights probably uh configuring
I hate every day I'm away stones dude
you need a strength train he's like I
have these pains here are these pains
here I hate it Nick I hate it yeah but
you have to learn to love it I'm not
gonna bully you dude no one at the gym
that we're at at Pasadena strano the
last time we wait trained I cried hey
man it's cool huh sure I don't even have
that many bad associations so I
shouldn't be like taking weights out of
people [ __ ] the first time that actually
happened to me and it was from a lady
cuz she was in the zone with the music
and [ __ ] and then like you know that
pull down weight the Machine oh yeah one
lighter and I was like what the [ __ ] and
I looked back and then the lady had the
weight in her hand and she was walking
away and she's like [ __ ] dancing and
she had music in her ears and I was like
this lady so I had to tell her like
excuse me like you just took that from
my machine yeah and she's like oh my god
I'm so sorry I'm like it's cool you're
just in the zone like whatever I took it
back and I'm like that [ __ ] is crazy
yeah some people most people are just
inconsiderate and they don't know like
there's just she was just in the zone
like she was on meth or whatever in
general though like you know what you're
doing yeah like I wish my guy was like
that he was just having the time of his
[ __ ] life yeah
but ya know that [ __ ] way and I
snatched it up what are you doing whoo
you know yeah yeah that's all you did
that on purpose I started to drop kick
though I started very unathletic line up
I was like weighing a buck 20 like 120
pounds um when I first started like I
was with my other buddy he was hella
skinny too he was a DJ and his other
friend just got him it cuz he's got a
pretty good pretty good like body like
he was like like into that [ __ ] like I
want to be an actor model kind of guy
right
and then he's like yeah I'm starting to
workout now come on and then he got me
this like free pass at 24 hour and then
I signed up and I remember my first
benchpress I had my my top that I can do
was 210 pounds at the end that that was
it
I couldn't that was like my max and I
can [ __ ] him press that like twice that
was me in high school yeah and I'm like
damn dude I didn't get strong yeah and
then I I wasn't doing much so it just
you know it kind of came hand-in-hand
cuz I wasn't eating much doing much a
lot of drugs and [ __ ] so I would just
work out eat food get bigger and bigger
and bigger and then like I started
liking it yeah because I started liking
how this body felt actually being used
uh-huh and it was always fun because
like this we go in groups we work out we
have dinner we hang out sometimes we
work out take a nap work out again like
yeah that's all we did you saw the value
in it yeah so I always had a positive
like no feeling about doing that with my
friends
um so I never had that much like weird
interactions at the gym yeah yeah and I
did feel like I was the I was like you
had you know how you had the the fat guy
was right yeah I felt the skinny guy was
like I wasn't really skinny here I mean
both yeah I was like chicken leg [ __ ]
straight up no chest like I was skeleton
with skin yeah and I thought to myself
that oh Asians just can't get buff yeah
and Asians can't build muscle and we do
have high metabolism like generally but
disprove that very you know like a child
the pig we do have the opposite problem
which is building muscle fat muscle mass
and and and everything but also like we
just didn't see an example of fit Asian
guys yeah so I think that's super
important is to see that it's possible
so you know that like all you got to do
is it's like work out and then you can
get there now it's not a question but I
grew up with the stereotype of Oh Asians
just can't get buff yeah they're not
like black people like or or white
people it's like
but that's how how stupid is that to
think that like now it's like duh
everybody could get ripped it doesn't
matter what race you are yeah my mom
used to tell me that when I was a kid
Asians can't get ripped well like she
would say I work out Nick yeah why she's
like you little [ __ ] anyway I know
mommy loves you yeah yeah when I would
step out of the house and I wouldn't
wear a sweater she's like why are you
stepping like wear a sweater you're
gonna catch a cold you know like white
people are black people they could do
that but you can't they start like the
plague all right what your mom's logic
is so [ __ ] hilarious
yeah but then in my head like growing up
like that became a part of like my
narrative like I went to saw the outside
world but like you said going back to
what you were saying about how people
can anybody can build muscle anyone can
lose weight whatever it just takes like
that first couple steps in that's the
hardest part
yep you know and it you just need to
stick with it because people want
instant results I get so many clients
that that are asking for I want to lose
this weight and X amount of days yeah I
could tell him I have to frame life to
like frame the the process with them
that it doesn't happen that quick and I
explained to them why it doesn't happen
that way and eventually they're like oh
okay because there's so much [ __ ] in
the fitness world which is probably
another barrier why yeah I mean if it
took you five years to become obese what
makes you think I'm in in one month
you're gonna wipe that all away most
people don't want to hear the truth
about it because they want everything's
about instantaneous results and
everything that we have now is about
instant results fifty even even like for
example Amazon [ __ ] right a majority of
this stuff that I feel that people buy
from Amazon specific let's talk about me
let's just not say majority people a lot
of the stuff that I buy from Amazon if I
plan it outright I don't need it the day
after yeah so if I see that I'm low on
type AWS and detergent I could probably
order that six seven days ahead but
we're so used to having instantaneous
things I like the fact that I could get
my stuff to the very next day when a lot
of it has to do with planning you know
and we're just not used that we're very
used to instant gratification yeah
instagrams both that way Twitter's built
that way I want that burger right now
yeah that's that's a lot another reason
why I found out that I was gaining so
much weight because a lot of the food
that I have if you look look at it
I shouldn't have it whenever I want it
doesn't make sense you know pride for
everything being you know mass per
Joost and stuff if I wanted to eat
something let's just say I wanted to eat
a [ __ ] I don't know a stay even a
steak right I would have to raise this
cow I would have to butcher it split it
up and eat it right but now we have it
so accessible whenever we want I could
have rib eye four times a [ __ ] day
like it's nothing yeah and just
typically if you kind of put it within
that framework it kind of makes sense
it's like oh maybe I shouldn't eat a
hamburger four times because if I had
him create this burger from scratch
would I eat this hamburger four times
then most likely when you're starving
you're gonna cook something these
simplest and the fastest way pal yeah
oatmeal you'll get a veggie you'll get a
meat you'll stir-fry that [ __ ] or
something cook it up and you're it's
right in that's all we at the done house
okay because I'm gonna blanch some
[ __ ] kale like we knew had in Typhon
by the way I saw you made that and I
started making it too [ __ ] delicious
right so far but then and then it's like
a steak maybe some sweet potato mash and
that's it yeah be a little bit of rice
and that's it and I'm full for a really
long time I don't need to eat anything
else and you have good protein yeah
because but also don't look at food like
an energy source anymore now it's just
more for entertainment it is every meal
that I need to have it needs to be
different it can't be the same from
yesterday's meal it has to be something
fresh and I have and it's just that
concept so growing up too I remember my
mom would just make a big pot of soup
and then we would have that maybe for
3-4 days we'd have leftovers like our
grandparents were starving and we're
just we don't even know what that's like
we're in abundance humans are amazing
due to in a very short period of time we
went from like nothing to abundance yeah
and having an obesity epidemic you know
well in America well there's other
places in the world that's hungry as
[ __ ]
definitely it's crazy man I don't know
um it just blows my mind when I think
about the whole world in general because
we can get food to these places we can
we can we can literally solve world
hunger right now there's enough food
that's being produced that everybody can
eat plentifully know the hard part is
the logistics mm-hmm and there's no
profit in that yeah so yeah because
people don't care exactly that's it's
just [ __ ] up but I mean going back to
the whole fitness thing right I know
like when you did a funny fat fit you
motivated a lot of people just by you
challenging yourself you know but
there's also all
lot of [ __ ] out there that make people
feel like [ __ ] yeah because you'll see
these guys that are like I lost weight
in two months and then they all of a
sudden got a six-pack [ __ ] you
took steroids straight steroids
you [ __ ] starved yourself you you sat
in the gym for four hours a day and
you're already an influencer so you have
all this [ __ ] money but people are
working like regular jobs you know and
if they're like full-time students or
whatever they don't really have the same
time as this influencer who's like kind
of chub or whatever and all of a sudden
they got a six-pack and it's like now
you can do it to take a program and
nobody's talking about that much no no
and that's the most [ __ ] up [ __ ] a lot
of these programs that are out there
they're being sold they're all based on
people that have steroids in their
system yeah and it yeah this lot of the
programs that are out there they have so
much frequency so much volume that a
normal person will not have the time to
do it it's a program that you're
supposed to take with steroids exactly
like that is that's a prerequisite and
that message isn't being shared enough
like a lot of your favorite like
Instagram people that are that are like
making so much money off of this [ __ ]
yep and they're putting out just bad
programming everywhere you see and
there's enough it makes people feel like
[ __ ] because they're like man I followed
this program to the tee yeah and they
[ __ ] got a six pack in two months but
it's taken me one year yeah [ __ ] suck
yeah they're not following the right
people that are giving this the right
message that's that's that's necessary
my favorite thing that I think I started
implementing was putting it within the
framework that works for me
yeah right so people still don't
understand what I mean by walking every
day right that's something that every
body can do and you can make time for it
and I can I also say about the walking
is that that is like design for body
builders at the highest level like
taking 10-minute walks is so important
for like athletes across the board
people trying to build muscle trying to
lose weight that is something that is
necessary like to get lean every like
all the top strength coaches fitness
experts that are actually legit they
recommend that for everybody because in
ten minutes every day that dude that's
that
that helps on top of obviously your
physical activity and you're eating
clean and all those things but like that
is so important for people to do that
nobody kind of understands that you're
right because we walk a [ __ ] ton in
Japan yeah and there's so much food yeah
but there's no there you don't see
obesity there yeah and I actually ate
more out there than I did here but I
walk for like five ten hours every
[ __ ] day yeah and I actually lost
weight exactly because here's this guy
crazy if people don't talk about this
enough unless you're listening to the
right fitness people but like for you
how were you able to lose all that
weight was I'm sure those walks for you
guys were like very therapeutic Yeah
right it was a time for you to kind of
unwind where you can get out of the
sympathetic nervous system state where
you're just always stressed stressed
stressed out stress and you're able to
kind of unwind and bring yourself down
there's no way you're gonna be able to
lose weight in an efficient way if
you're always in the sympathetic this
stressed out oh yeah you know so you
need that that's why I like people I
have a couple clients that are having
trouble losing some weight and I'm like
how's your sleep and they're like it's
[ __ ] now well you're not gonna lose
weight I'm sorry like you need to you
need to get that down you need to
implement some sort of practice where
you can kind of bring yourself down in
this state where you're unstressed
you're not taking anything any like too
much stimulus and you're you can able to
relax because that will help you build
muscle lose weight and that's for
everybody people has to wrap their head
around this - it's just you know being
motivated momentarily is the easiest
part it is how are you gonna do that for
the rest of your life so when you
implement a lot of the stuff that you're
gonna do like I floated now from like
2:15 to like 2:05 right that's that's
where I generally stay depending if I do
like a send foods binge and then I gain
weight because of all the food that I'm
eating but I you know it's not hard for
me to manage and Muriel and I were
having a conversation the other day
where I kind of told it where I think we
probably even talked about on the
podcast where people think that your
your body is very [ __ ] intelligent
the fact that the human being the human
body can even balloon up to nine hundred
pounds and still survive right and then
you can go down to even people who
suffer from you know anorexia they have
like zero nutrients in their body and
they still survive the human body is
[ __ ] amazing
so I think it's very adaptive it is
smart it knows what it wants exactly
[ __ ] knows what it wants like after I
do want us honest n foods binge when I
come back I'm not sitting here thinking
to myself I want to eat a burger I want
pasta cuz I just had all that stuff I I
sit home and for some reason I crave raw
vegetable I crave all this other stuff
and my appetite shrinks down because I
just don't need it the body's adaptive
dude so whatever stress you put on the
body the body will adapt and no matter
what so you people have to think about
that when they're trying to do their
weight loss or their fitness and
especially just eating right in general
you know it's just it's the whole thing
of to just it's all these like meme
sayings to like trust the process and
you know kind of enjoy what you're doing
every day
it's a journey you know my friend but
one of my friends he's struggling with
his weight and I told him about the walk
with egos now I can't do that but I'm
telling him I'm like bro you're 300
something pounds you're gonna have to do
sorry and you're [ __ ] running on a
track I was like what happened dude he
goes I blew out my knee yeah of course
you blew out your [ __ ] knee do much
weight on the knee yeah and I was like
you you were gotta walk before you run
man most people can't run dude Yoos
people can't run right if you're not if
you don't have like a if you never had
like a formal running coach like
apparently there's there's like a
there's a statistic it's saying that
like where every time you run every step
you take that's seven times your body
weight coming down yeah I agree I have
no kneecaps because exam we're not
running because of our shoes [ __ ] us
over like we're not running correctly
like exactly we're not supposed to have
shoes running to be running barefoot you
should have your running technique
analyzed if you could do that and and
that then you can start maybe running
but yeah there's four bigger clients
like you need to have something like
yeah and rower by the way this guy too
and bro I know you're listening to this
[ __ ] [ __ ] guy I told you this last
time and you blew out your [ __ ] knee
and number one you never played any
sports with us ever growing up yeah so
what the [ __ ] were you thinking right
and I and for him he goes not that's too
boring for me well that's your problem
because you always want instant results
and I've told him multiple times now I'm
not beating it over his [ __ ] head but
he's just a very very stubborn guy and
he wants to do things the way he does it
and he's never works out and you know
the [ __ ] it doesn't work out we just
talked about this last week
where
I keep telling him it's it's the process
that you have to trust right and what
you do is you get this little bit of
success and you go god I got it down
figured it out and then you know when
then when he reaches a little bit of
adversity in his weight loss thing he
goes I'm done what's the whole point
yeah and the reason why is because
number one you didn't touch the process
and you you just want instantaneous
results when I was first doing those box
that first month I lost maybe a pound I
was walking like three four miles a
[ __ ] day and I just had to say cool
that's one pound that I didn't have
before I'll take it the next month I
don't know what happened
maybe it weighed a pound in 3-4 days no
I lost a pound in a month
oh I was like that's insane I lost one
maybe one or two pounds it knows
obviously because I just said I'm not
gonna worry about the food part yet I'll
work on that
on the second phase one at a time yeah
so in the first month when I was doing
the walks
I lost maybe one or two pounds or
something like that it was very nominal
I can't remember what the number is but
it wasn't above two pounds and within
that month I was reading about diets
what food does to you and then I started
implementing the diet part on the second
month and then while I was doing these
walks the walks increased in length time
they almost got addictive and then on
top of that I started eating a little
bit better and then the second 115
pounds disappeared I wasn't starving
myself I just made these minor changes
but yeah you set yourself up but I
always say that you know people have to
be mentally prepared yeah or they do the
thing the easiest part is actually doing
the thing but what what happens when you
feel adversity when you're when you feel
discomfort that's the that's the real
habit building part yeah yeah yeah what
do you do how do you react to that and a
lot of people don't want to deal with it
because it's hard like just it's not
because they're weak it's just they
haven't built the habits yet to overcome
it yeah and I think the biggest thing is
they haven't been rewarded yet yeah so
like they can't trust the process
because every time they in the middle of
the process they give up so they haven't
went through the process ever so they
don't know what it's like on the other
side you know once you've done it once
you've lost weight once you know you can
do it now it's all about getting in the
gym and yeah sticking to your routine
having a discipline I think for my
friend too and
like I said I've had this conversation
with before me and I'm being harsh on
because we've been friends for [ __ ]
years but I would never say this is
somebody didn't know but we talked about
his issues with a personal
responsibility yeah there's always a
reason for something and this is not
just something that's representative and
how he eats food it's how he's been
behaving throughout life every time
something bad happened to him it was oh
it was because of this it was never
because I [ __ ] up yeah I made the
choice you know so for him too he goes
yep you know nobody wants I'm just gonna
stay fed I'd hurt my knee I was and I
told him it was a sign yeah you need to
take the responsibility that your three
hundred and something pounds and you
decide to try to run a [ __ ] mile
right on concrete yeah well David gagas
did it yeah David Goggins is a maniac
and he also has no kneecaps and he's a
Navy SEALs yeah so that's a very unique
person yeah when I took the David
Goggins advice I took 1% of what he said
exactly I knew I wasn't gonna do what he
did you have to scale it yeah you have
to scale certain things you have to and
it's really important that's that's the
whole thing about like the fitness
industry going back to the top you hear
everyone's like oh you want to lose
weight bunch of cardio that's gonna be
great so what does this person do I got
a run everyone if you want to lose
weight you've got to run yeah you know
and if that's that's not how it's
supposed to be you have to scale it to
you but it's not necessarily his fault
just because he didn't know you know but
it's it's it's a product of you know
misinformation the same same advice too
and I think he's working with it now and
you know he's gonna start trying these
walks out I have to check up on him
every every now and then to give him
like words of affirmation and help him
out at the end of the day just make it
fun yeah they did fire you it's it
shouldn't ever be like oh like a chore I
gotta clean my room you know it should
be more like oh yeah I get to have fun
today
and the gratitude part is very important
yeah that's another reason why people
are there's another barrier for the
fitness in it
you know to get into fitness or into
working out it's things like that I do
something I'm trying to I'm ready to do
it I do it and then you blow your knee
out you engineers yeah it's too much
motivation yeah because you're just
trying to oh and then in and it's kind
of a high like when you're first getting
in the runner's high or whatever you
feel powerful you're like lifting you
feel great
and then you just want to keep going and
going and going and it's like you got to
know your limits yeah I think we all
been there right definitely is it's all
about resolve yeah overdone it no it's
the right framework because when I would
try to weight train with Bart you know
he would always tell me stop going so
[ __ ] ham but I would I would [ __ ]
go and the next day I would be sore for
three months vomit ah you traumatize
yourself as myself yeah so I guess what
you don't strength train train but
anyways water what are some wrapping up
thoughts that we can do oh yeah oh [ __ ]
damn that was crazy
um yeah I mean just to go back to it and
the reason why we bring up all the stuff
too and you know I'm talking about my
buddy now which by the way good job man
you're going at it this is why that
Fitness stuff makes sense for for a
bigger crowd yeah the people that are
going through it every day he's going
through it I went through it and why not
allow them to wear stuff or create
products for them to feel good about
themselves that's the first step anyways
that's not I'm thankful for Nike to do
it yeah this cuz I think it's gonna help
people feel like included and for me at
least I feel like everybody should go to
the gym hold young everyone everybody me
it's very great for mental health and
just everything everybody there's no
reason for no one to train yeah I want
everyone to have a nice ass Joe's got a
great one yeah well thank you well guys
well shout out to my homie I know I'm
giving you a little [ __ ] but very proud
of you dude keep going at it I love you
very much
I only give you [ __ ] because that's the
way you communicate and that's how you
process information you son of a [ __ ]
stubborn mules
yeah those types he likes it so let me
give to him that way anyways guys that
wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast thank you guys for joining
in you can find us on every single audio
platform make sure that you share all
this [ __ ] with all your friends and then
on top of that give us that five star on
iTunes Nick where can they find you
again
you find me at Nick de here.com Nick
they're on Instagram and Nick the ear on
YouTube he is certified in everything
was that CSCS training with Nick the SES
baby intra strength conditioning on
command workout toodle-loo mata asses
peace mother asses